data not dates that's what we're told it
was going to be all about well what is
that data telling us
about the unlocking uh of this country
have a look
at those four tests the government laid
out what we're going to do is go through
each of them look at the numbers
see what they're telling us and start
with this vaccine deployments are
vaccines getting out quickly enough are
they getting into arms well here we can
look
at antibodies the proportion of adults
who have antibodies and that they're
going up very quickly faster actually
than many people had expected fossil in
many other countries
up to about 70 to 80 percent of all
adults
having those antibodies similar numbers
when you look at the number who've had
one jab so that's really encouraging
going up very quickly whether it's near
heard immunity or not we'll have to wait
and see but that looks pretty good the
first test the second test
is looking at whether those vaccines are
reducing hospitalizations and deaths
in those who have been vaccinated here
we can break down hospitalizations
by age group because of course you know
those over uh
64 have more of them have been
vaccinated we can look at
hospitalizations among those
under 65 they're starting to creep up so
that's going up a little bit but now
compare that
with those who are 65 and over they are
basically flat at the moment if anything
going down and the gap between those two
is really encouraging especially given
that that dark line has been above the
yellow line for most of this pandemic so
that's encouraging on the first
two of those tests but now let's get to
the third of them looking at
infection rates so cases across the uk
are they going up basically
and here the picture is slightly less
encouraging have a look at that well it
doesn't look that bad there does it that
little
rise on the far right but now let's look
at the same chart same data but with a
logarithmic scale
showing you the growth profile and when
you look at the growth profile the
logarithmic axis
it does look more worrying doesn't it
actually growing by about
seven percent a day uh on average over
the course of the last
week or so now if you compare that with
what was happening in september it's not
quite as steep so that's
perhaps relatively encouraging but still
seven percent is quite a lot and if we
extrapolate that
over the course of the next few weeks
well here's what it implies we're
talking about getting to about 10
000 cases a day by june the 21st of
course that
unlocking day and then getting to over
20 000 by the end of the month that's
just an extrapolation of course so that
you know it's not a forecast
but that might be concerning for those
looking at these numbers finally
new variants of course so much focus on
these variants recently
and if we have a look at the profile the
growth profile of those variants
was a pretty clear picture here this
shows you the south african variant and
just how much it grew after it got past
10 cases
this is the kent variant and what we're
just comparing is the steepness of the
lines here
and now look at the indium the delta
variant it is up
so sharply that actually it now accounts
for over
90 percent of all of those cases more
transmissible potentially more severe
as well so more hospitalizations when
you look at the the impact of it
take that test take the previous one not
looking so encouraging the first two
looking pretty good so
two out of four we'll have to wait and
see what the government makes of it all